hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur snapshot
vorstellung von dem neuen snapshot 12 b
42 a also in diesem snapshot ist nicht
allzu viel dazu gekommen es wurde ein
wenig beim amboss verbessert allerdings
werde ich dazu entweder heute abend oder
ich denke er morgen noch ein extra video
zum amboss machen damit ich euch den ein
bisschen besser erkläre also da ist er
zum beispiel eine billigere herstellung
man braucht zum beispiel nur noch vier
eisenwaren und drei eisen blöcke anstatt
sechs und eine minimale änderungen am
modell und so weiter reparaturkosten
gesenkt also da sind so ein paar sachen
verbessert worden aber dazu alles mehr
morgen in einem extra video zum amboss
und ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt
man mit den wenigen änderungen von
snapshot 12 42 an ich habe gesagt ich
werde jeden snapshot vorstellen egal wie
viel neues damit ihr einfach auf dem
neuesten stand sein und wir fangen
direkt im multiplayer an
hier seht ihr meine server da ist einmal
der letzte server wo ich dazu zeit
ambauen bin ja da wird bald wieder eine
folge kommen ein privater server von mir
und die today show ihr braucht übrigens
nirgendwo versuchen darauf zu connecten
weil überall nur weil es drauf ist die
ihr schon wusste mit f1 können einfach
drücken dann sind die hippen also wenn
man videos macht und ich will dass man
die sieht kann man einfach f1 drücken
allerdings was man jetzt auch machen
kann wenn ich zb gescher wenn ich nicht
will dass ihr die ip sät kann ich
einfach auf edit gehen heute dress jetzt
und dann ist er alleine gehandelt also
versteckt sagt wenn ich jetzt f1 drücken
sind die alle weg und wenn ich wieder
auf eindruck ist er immer noch weg also
das kann man nun hier alles um ändern
jetzt seht ihr den wieder also dass es
halt mit dem server update worden
außerdem wurden die sprachdateien
geupdatet also mal wieder so ein paar
änderungen an den ganzen sounds wenn man
schnell platziert und so weiter oder
gras es ist ja alles ein bisschen anders
und was ich ganz cool finde für mich als
redstone neuling kann ich euch dass nun
auch vorstellen repeater kann nun
gesperrt werden das heißt wenn ich hier
ein signal habe also ich jetzt eine
fackel hin
zack zack zack zack und hier setzt sich
ein repeater hin und hier seitlich einen
dagegen dann ist hier so ein balken also
das signal es geklappt sei es sich
kanonier wieder ein signal
und dann hat er diese signale quasi
gekappt sag ich mal das gleiche kann ich
jetzt auch machen wenn ich das hier
einfach wegnehmen würde moment so und
das ganze hier denn so machen würde dann
wäre das hier auch so oder so nur halt
so geht es wiederum nicht also man kann
im redstone signale kappen
also das ist wirklich eine ganz coole
änderung für ein paar redstone sachen
bald wird auch wieder eine redstone
folge kommen beziehungsweise sogar eine
serie also da könnt ihr euch darauf
freuen
und ja das war es doch eigentlich schon
von den ganzen änderungen also es gibt
noch bug fix ist die kann ich euch mal
ganz gut sagen und zwar fledermäuse die
zertrampeln keine fehler mehr und die
lösung auch keine druckplatten mehr aus
also damals war es so dass fledermäuse
wenn die auf einer holzplatte gegangen
sind
dann wurde das aus klöstern hat sich zb
die tür geöffnet oder sogar weg danke
tschüss
jetzt kommt das ja noch ja kein geister
mehr beim fallen lassen eine stark
beschädigten amboss von einer höher
größerer größer sechs blöcken
das war nämlich damals so dass wenn man
einen amboss höher gebaut hat dass das
dann irgendwelche bucks mit sich trug es
gab auch den bug das präsidentenpaar
gedreht hat oder so aber jetzt lässt er
auch dann keine komischen alten
verfallen es gibt doch keine geister
block mehr beim senkrechten graben also
das wird mal wieder gefixed also das
hatten sie auch schon mal dass man
einfach wenn man gegraben hat kann auf
einmal irgendwelche items die man gar
nicht kannte so war das ja auch damals
bei diesem blog der hieß damals auch
work in progress mode blog bei
ausgeschaltetem pvp kann kein schaden
über schwerter mitverbrennung ausgeteilt
werden
also wenn ihr pvp auf dem server aus
habt und ihr schlagt ein schwert des
uncharted mitverbrennung sage ich mal
da war es damals so also 1 punkt 3.32
zwar kein schaden kriegt aber der kriegt
ist der fink anhalt an zu brennen
dass es nun weckt ein falscher hatten
wir beim fallen aus niedrigen höhen also
wenn man von einer ganz ganz niedrigen
moment kann es nicht sein
moment ich mach das mal ganz kurz
im moment hat das kann man testen welche
zeit ein game und 0
zu 1 nein nein jetzt muss ich noch kurz
das abbauen
also hört gerade schon die neuen sounds
es hat sich alles ein bisschen sandig an
also ich fange jetzt einfach hier runter
ich bekomm trotzdem schaden naja
wahrscheinlich irgendwie mit kleinen
helfer so was gemeint aber bekomme ich
auch schon verstehe ich nicht und es
gibt noch weitere kleine bugfixes die
halt immer dabei sind und na ja das
war's halt schon die meisten änderung
hatte wirklich also dieses red storm
repeat allerdings und der amboss aber
zum amboss kommt dann morgen ein neues
video und heute abend kommt auch noch
ein schönes video worauf ich
wahrscheinlich alle freuen werdet und
was euch gefallen wird und dann würde
ich einfach sagen wenn ihr das video gut
fand dann bewertetes bitte mit einem
daumen hoch wenn nicht so gut dann bitte
mit einem daumen runter und schreibt mir
nochmal einen kommentar
ob ihr findet das minecraft in die
richtige richtung geht mit diesen ganzen
änderungen und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir zunächst mal tschüss